Dollar Loan Center the sponsor of this
segment has been in Las Vegas for almost
25 years with more than 36 locations
just in southern Nevada so founder and
CEO Chuck Brennan is here to tell us
more about their efforts to loan a
helping hand welcome Chuck how are you
I'm good I've been doing business in
dollar in Vegas for 25 years but at
Channel 8 for about 20. how do you like
it here well it's been a great three
years what's the interview here three
years already it's been a great three
years we love channeling it all on
Sunday well we love you because we were
JC and I were just talking about how
your voice is so prominent here because
you're on the radio we all know the
jingle to Dollar Loan Center the don't
be broke.com I try to stay off
television my wife says I have a great
face for radio so I don't want to hear
it you know we're on radio stations
everywhere and I voice up my own ads so
people do think they they know me right
when I go in somewhere I know you from
somewhere now you probably just heard my
annoying voice on the radio for a long
time even when you walked in the studio
you were singing my jingle I was so we
did a good job yeah you guys are more
than just a brilliant advertisement
company though but you what do you guys
actually do what do you provide tell
everybody that well I think I'm probably
a marketing company that lends money but
we actually do a really good job of of
lending money and we do have 36
locations here we've been in business
for 25 years in Vegas we feel we're
really a part of the community and we've
even stepped it up you know big time
with our new Dollar Loan Center Arena
now in Henderson at our partnership with
uh fully Entertainment Group in the city
of Henderson and and we just are Vegas
we're involved in in all the local
charities we have more customers here
than any bank by far wow 250 000
customers in Nevada that we've been
lending money for 25 years and we
started with one little location of
stone's throw from here over at Saharan
Burnham and you know we love Vegas we
love our customers we love our employees
we love our channel eight yeah what you
do for the community and what's
separates you guys though from from the
competitors in town because right here
you get more time to pay you back and
that's super helpful it is and look we
tell people to pay back as quick as they
can and our average loan is only a
thousand dollars it's a short-term
bridge loan that people need to get by
and and look if they pay it off in three
days they pay three days worth of
Interest they pay it off in a year it's
on them they pay a Year's worth of
interest but the loans are short but for
the most part I think the the big thing
we're doing right now when you ask about
that is since we are here for 25 years
uh for the first time ever we're giving
free loans this holiday season we
started Black Friday we're going till
the end of the year and basically no
application fee no origination fee
nothing and the first week's on us so
wow you borrow 500 a thousand five
thousand whatever you borrow pay it back
in a week check us out see how it works
that's just the principle thank you so
much I'm sure that's really helpful of
course during the holidays too so thank
you to Dollar Loan Center for sponsoring
this segment again 36 locations in Las
Vegas and for the first time ever DLC is
offering one week free interest on loans
up to five thousand dollars you can fly
at don't be broke.com
[Music]